in the united kingdom pies are king
not just for the cherries and the apples
that you yanks are used to you have your
chicken your steak and kidney your pork
pie
and in one tiny fishing town you have
this a pie with what wait is it is that
fish head
oh you've gotta be kidding me
trust me you're gonna love it
in this tiny fishing village there's a
pub and in that pub they make stargazey
pie it's a tradition that legend has it
has been happening here for hundreds of
years which begs the question why the
starry gazy pie is a pie which
celebrates tombow cox going out and
catching seven different kinds of fish
on the 23rd of december
you see according to the legend it had
been a stormy winter this meant no boat
managed to go out of the fish so people
were starving but a local fisherman tom
bocox he wasn't going to let his people
die i'm going he went out through the
gate yes that gate and braved the storm
and
and caught the different kinds of fish
and brought it back he made the pie
and that brings us to today tracy take
it away you get six different white fish
bake that in the oven with some herbs
and some lemon zest put a layer of
grated eggs a nice mashed potato with
loads of cream in and then you put a
pastry lid put pilchards cut them and
then you put so that the heads are
coming out the pie and the tails are
coming out the pie you assemble all the
stars around the pie
on the 23rd of december we give it away
free to thousands of people that come to
the village to celebrate tom pocock's
night so to tom bocox what a legend
cheers tom
so should we taste it
that is good
delicious that really is quite delicious
it's good
really good
the fish is lovely it's most interesting
it's it's much milder than i thought
fishbone